[Music]
all right fake News CNN still refusing
to retract their botched Trump Tower
story earlier today the president
tweeted fake news CNN is while yet at
the fake is being torn apart from within
based on their being caught in a major
live refusing to admit the mistake
sloppy call Bernstein a man who lives in
the past and things like a degenerate
fool making up story after story is
being laughed at all over the country
fake news it is at the end goes now with
reaction is counsel to the president
Kellyanne Conway you know I watched you
on the network right actually well I've
read the transcript and I watched
Mediaite puts up these these clips of
view and and Chris Cuomo I got along
well I get along with Chris and Don
Lemon I even have any issues with
anybody in the business except for fake
liberal Joe so I'm watching this and I'm
thinking oh I got a headache watching it
and I'm thinking I admire you for doing
it but I'm thinking why well I did I did
get two questions in about this very
topic that's burning a whole week later
twice if not three times I confronted
him with the fact that CNN including on
his show had let this life live for over
a month now and that this report this
bombshell report that they had talked
about had been quickly unraveling and
discredited and where they in fact admit
that and in his attempt to get me to
call the president United States the l
word which I would not do he was trying
to do that again and again and again and
again they've been caught I was going to
say
one question about this the rush the
rush to judgment i but i got in the
question about this particular issue
which now this particular story which
has been discredited that lanny davis
has admitted he made a mistake and he
didn't have the information but remember
what lanny davis said his client would
tell muller is central to the entire
claim of collusion which the president
says is phony and it's so essential to
the claim inclusion that without that
then all that bombshell report is just a
bomb but Sean this goes directly to the
problem we have which is
trust immediately tweet incessantly
verify never so long as it's negative
negative negative why won't CNN just say
look we it was based on false reporting
we retract it we apologize why can't
they just did it they had to do it they
had a fire three people three reporters
at CNN because they lied about anthias
Cara Moochie I'm meeting with Russians
for days we've before the inauguration
lie on that same host and the other host
from Sunday their Sunday show had lied
about Ted Cruz the senator being afraid
to talk to CNN why are they only giving
interview to the mothership Fox News
they asked very jealous of Fox News
always and yet senator Cruz had just
given a CNN reporter a 15 minute
on-camera interview that CNN had not
just here so people make mistakes but
those who are constantly sailing
everybody else are loath to admit it
I appreciate you running the president's
tweets about this because when the
president talks about fake news he's
really talking about two big things
which is inaccurate unfair imbalance
reporting and also sins of omission
not just commission probably a lot worse
why are you excluding all the important
information from America why aren't you
crowing about the economy why aren't you
telling them about the growth rate about
the job creation about the whole year 91
million dollars in running the present
age today the drug-free communities and
you know the answer they love Clinton
they loved Obama and they hate Bush and
Trump there are biased news so-called
news network but they won't admit that
their body I have a totally different
view on all of this by the way I'm not
sure it matters anymore Sean because the
President himself uses his considerable
social media platform our director of
social media today at the White House
Dan's Covino said in answer to the
president's question in an open press
forum that the president has about 160
million that's basically one of every
two adults in this country more than
that on one of his social media
platforms correct he connects directly
he doesn't need I don't think it matters
anymore because people know when they
open up the 401k statement when they see
that they've got extra spending money
well when they see less regulation and
more consumer confidence they know what
they see and this president is
connecting directly with them but you
also why won't they why won't they
investigate the other side
why is it Peter or leading the story on
every single Network tonight home has a
right to know in the interest of
transparency and accountability that
Christopher Steele was nervous he would
be up a creek without his or if Peter or
was if Bruce or was that the next ago
people are right to know maybe this FBI
DOJ taxpayer-funded paid person so
nervous about losing access and and the
last thing on it says they were
exchanged these messages not just in
2016 before Donald Trump was
democratically elect me a three hundred
and six electoral votes or e---coli they
were doing in 2017 2017 it's a problem
we should investigate it good to see you
always
you're always welcome here thank you